to most people ebola was a distant word
rarely spoken and even unknown to some
in the united states
it was a virus that people in rural
africa dealt with
but not americans but during the ebola
outbreak of 2014
the unfathomable happened ebola
crossed oceans and eventually made it to
our shores
predictive models suggested exponential
growth
sparking fear among health care workers
and public health officials
that we might be unable to control it
but along with that fear and all the
uncertainty that comes with
a virulent disease outbreak came some
positive outcomes
first we as citizens have a newfound
interest in and appreciation for public
health
we've learned that we can't take public
health for granted
and all of us play an important role in
keeping
our country safe we realize that
globalization
means that the rate at which an epidemic
can spread throughout the world
is now only a matter of days and being
on the other side of the ocean
doesn't keep us safe we are now
better aware of the needs for quarantine
to stop the spread of diseases
and have seen how breaking the rules can
put
an entire country at risk we also saw
firsthand
the multiplication factor of disease
that starts
with one infected person this
understanding
and the misfires that occurred when
ebola entered the united states
has resulted in improving our
capabilities
to defend ourselves against future
invaders
and we're going to need them
we are much better prepared as
individuals hospitals have better
systems and protocols in place
and hazmat suits and precautionary items
are well stocked the centers for disease
control
has had its dry run and it's changed the
way it handles the response to outbreaks
the ebola outbreak also sparked many
innovations
look what happened with drug development
for example
and international crises sparked an
unusual response from the food and drug
administration
rule breaking untested and unproven
treatments
were given to both americans and
africans
who were on the brink of death in other
words
they were willing to do whatever it took
to save lives
in spite of strict protocols and
regulations for drug development
and drug trials it's unclear what effect
this will have
on the future of drug development but it
was inspiring to see
how the global community pitched in to
try to stave off
complete disaster and save lives
other positive outcomes were new
technologies
or the use of old technologies
sometimes this was in the form of social
media
or apps to spread the word of pockets of
disease outbreaks
or the culling of keywords from the
internet searches
to try to put the pieces of a larger
puzzle together
this increase in the pace of
communication resulted in better
synchronization around the world
of information gathering which also
resulted in better response times
infectious diseases are unique in the
sense that unlike chronic diseases
they have the potential for explosive
global impacts
we have seen this phenomena over time
with some of the infectious diseases
of your as you will see infectious
disease spread
both past and present is largely
dependent
on how we interact with one another the
environments we live in
and even our interactions with the
animal world
during the ebola outbreak
epidemiologists and other scientists
were called in quickly to try to
determine the cause
and origin of disease they looked for
patient zero
traveling backwards to determine where
the very first human case originated
and then tried to find the ultimate
source of the disease
in this case cultural practices
especially funeral rites were a major
source of transmission
they tracked contacts to determine how
the disease
was passed from person to person how it
spread so quickly
to neighboring african countries
having specific protocols to track
disease patterns
allowed the virus to be somewhat
contained historically
when these protocols did not exist the
consequences were severe
well why should you be interested in
learning about infectious diseases
well on a worldwide scale infectious
diseases accounts for
26 percent of all deaths from
all causes secondary only to
cardiovascular diseases
although hiv tuberculosis and malaria
of the top individual killers combining
all respiratory and diarrhea related
diseases
accounts for about 10 of
all deaths worldwide roughly
6 million people today
we'll learn about three diseases plague
and malaria
which are two of the oldest infectious
diseases and
polio a disease of the mid-1900s
like ebola these diseases greatly
impacted the state of public health
often spreading through countries and
confidence
unchecked many people suffered
and died due to the lack of knowledge of
germ theory
or without the tools for diagnosis of
illness
best guess hypotheses abundant
on how people contracted and spread
disease
we'll look at some of these theories
some primitive treatments
and even how basic quarantined measures
affected the outcomes
infectious diseases have played a
significant role
in changing the course of human history
in erwin sherman's book
12 diseases that changed our world he
discusses diseases that have had
major social and political influences on
populations
one example from his book is the black
death
which originated in the hunan province
in
southwest china in 200 bc
and then was spread by italian merchant
ships to the rest of europe in the 1300s
ironically one of our favorite nursery
rhymes
ring around the rosie is allegedly a
testimony to this terrible illness
one of the symptoms of plague was a rosy
red rash
in the shape of a ring on the skin
people who believe that the plague was
transmitted by
bad smells carry posies to protect
themselves
and the ashes refers to the cremation of
bodies upon death
the last line of the song we all fall
down
pretty much says it all
now after i heard this interpretation i
felt the nursery rhyme would never again
bring to my mind
visions of joyful children holding hands
and singing
the black death also known as the plague
swept through europe
the middle east and africa and was
probably one of the greatest
health disasters in recorded history
estimates are the nearly 200 million
people worldwide died of the plague
and that it took europe four centuries
for its population
to recover let me paint a grisly picture
for you
in one form of the plague known as
bubonic plague
the victim's lymph nodes became hugely
swollen
and were called boobos giving bubonic
plague its name
buboes were hard painful burning lumps
and they often turn black hence spawning
the name
black plague and they split open and
they ooze pus
i know not a pretty sight this disease
was incredibly painful
and patients rarely survived more than
three or four days before dying
and of course antibiotics were not
discovered into the 1940s
so death was imminent
in the 1900s the plague even spread to
the united states
via rats aboard steam ships that had
sailed from infected areas
this resulted in around a thousand cases
in the u.s
predominantly in the western states and
where sporadic cases still occur today
but most present-day cases of plague
occur in rural africa a couple of
thousand cases yearly
but can you imagine the terror people
felt as they watched
family members die from this terrible
disease
why was the plague so deadly where did
it come from
and how did it spread well
theories abounded including the miasma
theory
that bad air poor hygiene
and contaminated water were the cause
this was the predominant theory of
disease transmission
up until the 1860s
some interesting but naive treatments
for plague
included witchcraft
quote place a live hen next to the
swelling
and draw out the pestilence from the
body unquote
lancing the lymph nodes quote the
swellings associated with the black
death
should be cut open to allow the disease
to leave the body
unquote concoctions to put on the lymph
nodes
quote a mixture of tree resin and roots
of white lilies
should be applied to the places where
the body has been cut open
unquote in the 1800s the founder of
modern-day nursing
florence nightingale was one of the
staunchest believers
that filth and unsanitary conditions
were a prime component
of disease transmission she brought
strict
new standards of sanitation to areas
filled with plague and malaria
even without fully understanding germ
theory
she saved many lives by just improving
sanitation and quarantining sick
patients
it became clear that plague was
contagious but up until the mid-19th
century
the concept of germ theory did not exist
so five centuries after plague appeared
only with the invention of the
microscope were we able to identify
microscopic organisms or germs
as the culprits
with this discovery of microorganisms we
celebrate
francis louis pasteur and germany's
robert [ __ ] for learning to assign
a specific microbe as the cause for a
specific disease
and over time we've learned that disease
outbreaks are sometimes caused from
bacteria
or viruses like influenza or
parasites like malaria we are now able
with modern technology
to determine the causes of most
infectious diseases
but where did all these germs originate
in the first place
germs are frequently transmitted from
animals
to humans in fact over 60 percent of
diseases
are thought to have their origins and
animals like monkeys
birds bats and rodents this is the case
with ebola as well
as fruit bats are the most likely
culprits and there's evidence that
influenza and hiv started in other
species
beware the major cause of this
transmission capacity
is the increased human activity in
wilderness areas
for example where rain forests are being
cut down
during an outbreak of plague in hong
kong
pasteur sent alexander yersen to try to
identify the germ
he drew fluid from a dead man's boobo
and looked at it under the microscope
he identified the bacterium later named
after him
called yersinia pestis
next he injected the germ into guinea
pigs
the pigs died a few days later and he
became convinced that he had identified
the plague germ
he also tested some of the dead street
rats and found
that they contain the same bacteria
the one thing left to figure out was how
the germ was transmitted
and pasteur sent a french army physician
paul luis simone
to try to figure out the vector of
transmission
simone determined that the real culprit
for disease transmission
was a little flea which fed on a rodent
that carried the bacteria and the flea
became the vector of the disease
transmitting it from animals to humans
you can see how easily
rat infested ports of call around the
world could serve as the impetus
for spreading diseases why was the
plague so hard to eliminate it could
remain
alive and potentially deadly even up to
three days later
in a dead body in addition there are
more than
80 species of fleas that can transmit
plague
fortunately with control of the flea
vectors and with
antibiotics given in a timely manner
today we can cure
85 percent of plague cases
so we see that efforts to stem the
spread of plague
were severely hampered by the lack of
knowledge of germ theory
and lack of tools like microscopes to be
able to identify
this pathogen let's turn our attention
to a dangerous parasitic disease
malaria and look at its tremendous
global impact
malaria is a parasite transmitted by
mosquito bites
which affects the functioning of our red
blood cells
which controls the delivery of oxygen to
the body
malaria is one of the oldest infectious
diseases
nearly half a million years old
and we've had plenty of time over
thousands of years to conquer malaria
yet malaria still manages to infect
one out of every 21 human beings on the
planet
and 300 million humans
yearly it kills nearly 1 million humans
year after year while the vast majority
of global malaria mortality is in africa
malaria frequently occurs in southeast
asia
and the amazon region of south america
interestingly malaria was still present
in the southern united united states
in the early 20th century and
malaria has also changed the course of
human history
let's wind back the clock to the
building of the panama canal in the
early 1900s
the wet and hot environment was the
perfect breeding ground for malaria
and another viral illness called yellow
fever
malaria killed over 30 000 workers
in 1897 the link between the mosquito
and malaria disease transmission was
proven and dr
william gorgas set out to eradicate the
insects
by eliminating standing water pouring
oil on immature malaria forms called
larvae
and by fumigation of living spaces
the reason malaria is so difficult to
eradicate
is that there is a continuous cycle of
infection occurring
first the infected mosquitoes carrying
the malaria parasite bite a human
and inject the parasite causing illness
meanwhile another mosquito that is
not infected bites the human who is
infected
and the mosquito becomes a new carrier
continuing the cycle
of transmission environmental factors
like global warming are thought to
predict a dismal future for malaria
which thrives in a warm environment this
makes for an uncertain future of malaria
there are ongoing efforts today by the
world health organization
or wh o to try to prevent and reduce
malaria illness
however in spite of all of our current
efforts
in africa one child still
dies every minute from malaria
unfortunately as a harbinger of the
problems with antimicrobial resistance
mosquitoes have developed resistance to
treatment drugs
from widespread misuse the mosquitoes
also seem resilient to widespread
pesticide applications
even ddt
this is a preventable and curable
illness that is still
causing unacceptable death rates
so even with the advances in medicine
new diagnostic tools and treatment
malaria continues to be a deadly disease
we know what the vector of the disease
is how it spreads
how to cure it but we're unable to
eradicate it
and like many other global issues it's
largely dependent upon
persistent efforts by dedicated
organizations and their partners
to raise money to enhance global
containment
does this mean that you should postpone
or cancel that trip to tanzania to visit
jane goodall's research station
no but i would suggest that you check
with your health care provider
or travel clinic before departing
let's move on to a newer infectious
disease of
epidemic proportions of the 20th century
poliomyelitis my mother-in-law
now 92 years old walks with a limp
and has a smaller right foot she has
right-sided leg weakness as well
why well she was a childhood victim
of poliomyelitis at the age of four in
rural north carolina in the late 1920s
and a lucky survivor
in his book polio an american story
david oshinski describes the first
recorded outbreak in the united states
in 1894 near rutland vermont
outbreaks of the disease increased
rapidly in the early 1900s
including new york city in 1916
all children leaving new york city were
required by the health department
to get a travel certificate proving that
they were
polio free an epidemic continued to
spread
including hyde park the elegant home of
franklin delano roosevelt
and i'll tell you a little secret fdr
had his wife and five children
remain out of the u.s on an island off
the canadian coast
during the summer of 1916 to keep them
from getting the virus
now 27 000 americans died that summer
80 percent of which were children under
the age of five years
and in 1921 fdr himself
would acquire polio
seven years after contracting the
illness fdr founded the national
institute
for infantile paralysis transforming the
landscape
of polio research the foundation which
later changed its name to the march of
dimes
was the first private large-scale effort
against the single disease do any of you
remember
donating to the march of dimes you
inserted a
winged liberty head dime into a small
cardboard slot and the money went
towards scientific research
to cure polio not until the 1930s
with the invention of the electron
microscope did scientists
identify this mysterious virus
it struck quickly without warning
causing mass
hysteria among the people of the
community that it invaded
people watched children struck down with
paralysis having no idea
how it was contracted how it spread or
what to do about it
polio was first described in the medical
literature
several hundred years ago and polio is
actually an intestinal virus infection
it is spread person to person through
contact with
fecal waste unwashed hands shared
objects
and contaminated food and water
polio enters the body through the mouth
travels into the digestive tract
and is eventually excreted the main
breeding ground for the virus
is the small intestine surprisingly
the most common infection it produces is
actually
an asymptomatic infection meaning with
no signs or symptoms or with minor
symptoms such as nausea and a headache
but in a small percentage of cases the
virus travels via the bloodstream
to the brain or the spinal cord
destroying nerve cells called
motor neurons which are responsible for
stimulating
muscles to contract the extent
and permanence of the resulting
paralysis is difficult to predict
as some infected nerve cells will fight
off the virus
and others will die at its worst
polio causes irreversible paralysis
most often of the legs the majority of
deaths occurred when the breathing
muscles were immobilized
you likely remember pictures of patients
being kept alive on machines
known as iron lungs an early feat of
biomedical engineering
where patients were confined in a tank
respirator
the first iron lung was developed in
1927 at harvard university
powered by a pump and two vacuum
cleaners
the pump changed the pressure inside the
airtight metal box
pulling air in and out of the lungs and
this invention was responsible for
saving many lives
during the peak of the polio epidemic
in addition there was an intense effort
to develop a vaccine against polio
in 1953 just after an epidemic year
where
58 000 new cases of polio were reported
and american medical researcher dr jonas
salk
announced on radio that he had
successfully tested
a polio vaccine from killed virus
strains
he even tested it on himself and his
family
now after conducting clinical trials in
over 12 million school children
the vaccine was deemed safe and
effective
it was widely distributed and amazingly
the total number of polio cases dropped
below 6 000
in the u.s in 1957 the first year the
vaccine was widely available in 1962
another scientist albert sabin developed
a
live weakened oral polio vaccine
but this vaccine had to be tested abroad
since the salk vaccine
was entrenched in the united states
now interestingly saban was able to
conduct
extensive polio vaccine trials in the
soviet union
at the height of the cold war because
the fear of polio
was stronger than political differences
in the first five months of 1959
10 million children in the soviet union
received the saben oriole oral vaccine
and he received a medal of gratitude
from the russian government
during the height of the cold war both
scientists donated the rights to the
vaccines
unpatented as gifts to humanity
in the 1960s the sabe and oral live
vaccine
would supersede the salk vaccine in the
united states
and eventually worldwide and in 1987
the who launched a global initiative
to eradicate polio from the planet
within 15 years
since remaining worldwide cases were in
limited geographic areas
of asia and africa there was reason for
optimism
and by the year 2000 there were fewer
than 2 000 cases
worldwide as of 2012
as a result of global efforts to
eradicate the disease
only three countries afghanistan nigeria
and pakistan
have polio cases and this was reduced
from more than 125 countries in
1988 now paradoxically
during the course of live vaccinations
there were actual cases of polio
that were caused by the polio live
vaccine
therefore in the united states the
vaccine was
reverted to an efficient kill version of
vaccine
like the salk vaccine but even in 2013
eradication of polio remained elusive
and the virus like ebola was spreading
via
international travel in spite of knowing
the epidemiology of the disease
the world's population is still at risk
polio reappeared in syria after a
15-year absence
and continues to persist in pakistan
afghanistan
parts of africa and iraq
it is particularly concerning in
war-torn areas
where even with vaccines available
people are difficult to reach
or people are refusing vaccination
fortunately we have a much stronger
public health system
with partners around the world pitching
in to eradicate
diseases innovative technologies
are providing better and faster tools
for diagnosis
which enables us to contain many
outbreaks
before they spread throughout countries
and continents
but does that mean we have to sit back
and just enjoy our progress
trusting that everything will be okay
the answer is a resounding no since
various diseases like measles and
whooping cough
have made a recent resurgence and exotic
diseases like monkey pox
and bird flu continue to emerge we'll
have to stay vigilant and rely on our
surveillance systems around the world
to be on the lookout for outbreaks that
have the potential
to become the next global infectious
disease
in the meantime i will leave you with
this tidbit
the study of infectious diseases relies
on skills similar to those
that sherlock holmes uses a penchant
for searching for clues studying
all aspects of a case in the minutes of
detail
assimilating multiple sets of incoming
information
and coming up with a conclusion which
can
be proven by scientific means
did you know that sir arthur conan doyle
included infectious diseases in his
sherlock home series in the 1880s
the golden age of microbiology he even
wrote about
bioterrorist acts long before we were
worried about them
in the adventure of the dying detective
a fatal infectious disease
likely plagued but called tapanuli fever
is used as a biological weapon a
criminal name
coverton smith tries to infect sherlock
with it
he even used the postal system to
deliver the virus
sound familiar in our next lecture
i'll begin to introduce you to some of
the basic elements of germ theory
beginning with bacteria how it attacks
our bodies
and how they can be deadly stay tuned